[Music]
wow
oh gosh sit down please
so hello everybody so nice to see
everybody
and um it's great to be back in southern
virginia
and really special to be here at
tidewater community college
and um now most people call me first
lady but
to one group of students at northern
virginia community college
i am first foremost and forever
their writing professor dr b so
no matter where i go i think i feel most
at home
at community colleges and so thank you
to
president constant for your warm welcome
and yes
and as a military mom i'm grateful for
how much
tidewater is doing to support veterans
and other military-connected students
actually i just met
uh one of the veterans that was in the
lab there
and to my colleagues and my fellow
educators
uh how many are professors here how many
people teach here
so a couple people okay so um
thank you for joining us and uh happy
teacher appreciation week so
[Applause]
so like the students here at tidewater
my community college students don't take
anything for granted so i don't get too
many
late papers or missed exams of course
although there are
as you know a few exceptions but i have
to tell you a few semesters ago
um it was early in the morning and i got
this
text and it said and i quote on my way
to the hospital to have my baby my
research paper is going to be late
to which i replied excuses excuses
now this woman in my class she served as
an
interpreter for our military in war
zones
and she had come to america to start you
know a new life with her family
and it missed i couldn't believe it but
in the midst of labor here she was
worried about
getting in her paper on time now i know
that she's a special example
but her commitment and you know this
is certainly isn't unique
and veterans and single parents first
generation
students refugees my students like all
the students here i'm sure come from
every walk of life they show
up they don't complain and all they
ask is for one thing in return
the chance to work hard and build a good
life
for themselves and their families and
that's
exactly what community colleges like
tidewater
give them our schools accept
everyone regardless of age or race or
income
or family legacy and they offer classes
that are flexible
so students don't have to choose between
work
and school they train for real
world jobs like i just saw in the lab
they tailor to the communities they
serve
or they provide a strong foundation for
those students who want to go on to
you know to a four-year degree community
college graduates promot
provide more security for their families
they invest in their local schools and
businesses
and they bring needed skills to our
workforce
helping us to meet the challenges of the
21st century
that's why we need two
years of free community college
thank you mr president and when we give
all americans the chance to learn from
preschool
to community college it will create a
ripple effect that is felt by every
single one of us
there is no greater investment than we
can make
than in education as we all know and we
must provide
support and resources so that our
students can
make it across the finish line joe knows
that
he saw it in his classes when he taught
law school
and he's heard it from me every single
day
when i finish teaching my classes
but it's not enough to know it takes
action
and what drew me to joe
all those many years ago was his
strength
and beneath his kindness and his charm
and his good humor is a man who keeps
his promises
he does the necessary work and shows up
when it matters and today the american
rescue plan
the american jobs plan and the american
families plan
will work together to deliver the future
we need
he's going to deliver on our promise
for of opportunity for all americans
with universal preschool quality public
schools
and free community college our
country is going to rise together and we
see that in the story of our next
speaker jayden williams
and when she was a senior in high school
she started taking classes
at tidewater and today she's part of the
tcc
stem promise program whose mission is to
create
a large and diverse stem workforce
so as you all know here at the community
college
it's all about good paying
jobs and jaden has made the president's
list and the dean's list
and is well on her way to a career
she loves jaden we are
all so proud of you so
please help me welcome jayden williams
hello everyone um i'm just so honored to
represent tidewater on this day because
of what this school
means to me tidewater community college
has equipped me to become a well-rounded
student
and professional tcc has provided me
numerous opportunities
to intern volunteer and also
earn professional development
tcc's women's center is very integral in
my story of my success
tcc women's center had actually offered
me a scholarship
that has eased my financial burden
completely
so i am on a full ride scholarship
thank you but
the thing that is so special about tcc
is the specialized support that we
receive and also
the smaller class sizes which i think is
a plus
i think that tcc's missions
from here go anywhere is essential just
everywhere in our daily lives
tcc has ingrained this in us and i
believe that
from here i can go anywhere
thank you
my name is joe biden i'm joel's husband
and just like uh uh
just like a lovely lady blue
over here is a professor at community
college
my wife also works for your husband
[Laughter]
i and thank you for the warm welcome day
at the airport appreciate very very much
and tim kaine one of the great senators
and a great great friend
and a guy i've relied on most of my
career when i was in the senate we
worked together
and uh as vice president and uh
now is uh bobby scott bobby thank you
for everything you do
and congressman laura we got to meet
when you're in uniform i think if i'm
not mistaken
and uh you're doing a great job and uh
thank you for uh for being here and all
the faculty and the
management and the folks here at
community college
you know uh one of the things that uh
um that i really uh found interesting
jayden is that uh
the major use talk cyber security
uh we spent a lot of time as my
colleagues uh in the congress and the
senate can tell you
worrying and dealing with cyber security
and uh it's really important that now
that we get this
under control we have the best trained
people in the world
you're going to be among them and i'm
here today at tidewater community
college to talk about america's family
plan
and that i announced last week a
once-in-a-generation investment in our
families
and our children that addresses uh what
people care most about and most need
the investment we need to win the
competition
the competition with other nations in
the future because we're in a race
we're in a race it all starts with
access to a good education as you all
know
when america made 12 years of public
education universal america
in the early 1900s it made us
the best educated nation in the world
and you saw the benefits that
came from that but the rest of the
world's caught up to us
the rest of the world's called up to us
they're not waiting and 12 years is no
longer enough
to compete with the world in the 21st
century
and lead the 21st century that's why my
american families plan
guarantees four additional years of
public education
for every person in america starting as
early as we can
we were at a an elementary school
earlier today
and what we're talking about here is
means universal high quality
preschool for three and four-year-olds
not
daycare pre-school
and the research is shown here at the
great universities in this state and
others that
children of that age who go to school
they are
far more likely to graduate from high
school and continue their education
beyond that
rather than start off behind the eight
ball if they come from families that
are not don't have educations college
educations
you know a lot of kids start
kindergarten hearing a million fewer
words haven't spoken in other families
and it's an unfair disadvantage but
every child is capable
every child is capable of learning so we
just visited by the way a fifth grade
classroom in yorktown earlier today
where the students
are back together with their classmates
and teachers in school
and we saw what what being in school
means
for those kids safely reopen the
majority of the k-8 schools was one of
my top priorities
in my first 100 days because there's so
much that happens when they don't
have the certitude and the and
the companionship and the familiarity
being with their friends there's an
awful lot of need
in this pandemic for mental health
facilities
and and counseling we met
that goal by working with governor here
to get educators and school staff
vaccinated
and to get them the resources they
needed to open up safely
i often said that children are the kite
strings
that keep our national ambitions of law
if you say all those kids well they're
all our children
they're all our children and they are
the kite strings that literally lift our
national ambitions along
so we've got to invest in them invest in
our children to invest in the future
we can't stop there we're going to add
two years of community college on top of
that
you just heard jill talk about community
colleges and how it can change
lives well students here at the
community college across the country
know why for some it's two years at
community college
to earn enough credits to transfer to a
four-year university which is available
almost every single state
to become a teacher an entrepreneur or
anything else for some it's getting an
extra training
through a certificate program to get a
good paying job
in a business in town we just met with
students at the hvac workshop ambitious
talented students who are up are to uh
taking the next step in their lives and
with the skills they're learning
here and some of the students will go on
to be plumbers members of pipefitters
local 110
electrician look it means higher union
wages with guaranteed healthcare and
pensions
and you know it's kind of amazing one of
the things i don't know you know
first lady of this state understands she
does i'm positive
that an awful lot of folks who uh
who even get an opportunity to go to
community college
still can't get there because of food
transportation those other costs
and so we're going to increase pell
grants
so they're qualified every single year
it will make a gigantic difference make
a gigantic difference
by the way i have to admit if i didn't
have these positions i'd be sleeping in
a lincoln bedroom
um rather than the vice the president's
been
but it really you know it really is how
to start to transform the life and
family and community in our economy
by investing investing in people every
child has the capacity to learn
and i've heard it once i've heard from
jill a thousand times joe
any country that out educates us will
out-compete us
as a fact and she'll be deeply involved
in leading this effort as well
the second thing the american family's
plan is going to provide access to
quality affordable child care keeping
parents
helping parents go back to work
providing a lifeline of benefits for
children as they
do better in school throughout their
lives you know it guarantees low and
middle income families pay
no more than seven percent of their
income for high quality care
for children up the age of five and
that's makes a gigantic difference
there's millions of women out of work
today not because they're not qualified
for the jobs they have
but they can't take care of their
children and do their job
and the cost of child care is
extraordinary
i was a single father when i first got
elected in the senate
two young boys raised after their mom
and sister were killed
and i've had i not had the family i had
i've never been able to do it
and i'm not joking about that and i was
a senator i was making a decent salary
the most hard-pressed working families
won't have to spend a dime
if in fact my plan works if you're
low-income
folks you'll be able to get child care
for free
third the american families plan is
going to finally provide up to 12 weeks
of paid and medical leave
paid family medical leave we're one of
the few industrialized countries in the
entire world
that doesn't have this feature no one
should have to choose between
a job and a paycheck or taking care of
themselves their parent their spouse or
a child
it's ill they should have that
opportunity
the fourth piece of the plan the
american family's plan puts money
directly in the pockets of millions of
americans
in march we extended the tax credit for
low and middle income families with
children
now like a hold a second here what you
know if you have make enough money
and you're paying taxes you end up in a
situation where
you get to deduct two thousand dollars
per child
as a tax benefit you don't get it back
but you get to deduct it
well if you're a minimum wage worker
you're not paying much tax
and if you're making less than that
which many people are you're not paying
any federal tax
you get no benefit so we put in place
and a number of my republican colleagues
share the view too
although none on voting for but they but
i think they share it as well
and that is up to three thousand dollars
per
child six years and older and thirty six
hundred dollars for a child
that is over six years under six years
of age
that means two parents and two young
kids
with they get a check back from the
government for seven thousand two
hundred dollars in their pockets
which they're doing now which can help
them take care of your family
and will benefit more than 65 million
children
and all the data shows will cut child
poverty in half
this year cut it in half my plan extends
the tax credit
at least through the year 2025. because
what's going to happen in 2025
as the press knows is that the tax cuts
of the last president expire
and we're going to go back that put us 2
trillion dollars in debt
and then we're going to compete as what
tax credits there are i think it's about
time we start giving tax breaks and tax
credits
to working class families and middle
class families
instead of just the very wealthy and
here's what the american family plan
doesn't do
it doesn't add a single penny to our
deficit
it's paid for by making sure corporate
america and the wealthiest one percent
just pay their fair share i come from
the corporate capital of the world
more corporations are incorporating the
state of delaware
then all the rest of the nation combined
and i'm not anti-corporate but it's
about time they start
paying their fair share it's about
making a choice
and you know we have out there this year
you have 50 corporations making you know
40 billion dollars that didn't pay a
single penny in taxes
not a single penny i don't want to
punish anybody but everybody should chip
in everybody should pay something along
the road here
the choice is about who the economy
serves
and so i plan on giving tax breaks to
the working-class folks
and making everybody pay their fair
share here's an example
of that choice if you ask the top one
percent to pay
the same tax rate they paid in 2001
when george bush was president that
would generate
13 billion dollars a year
now that's enough for us to take round
11 of that
13 billion and provide for two years of
community college free for every student
in america
so what's fair go from 36 to 39.6
like it used to be and be able to take
care of every what's better just
just think about it in terms of what's
better for america
not democrat republican what's going to
grow america more
what's going to grow america more what's
going to make us more competitive
stronger what's going to make us better
educated
so for folks at home i like to ask a
question
do we want to give the wealthiest people
in america another tax cut
or do you want to give every high school
graduate
the ability to earn a community college
degree on their way to good paying jobs
or on the way to four years of school in
industry of the future
healthcare i.t cybersecurity you name it
look another example for too long we've
had a two-tiered tax system
working families pay taxes they owe on
the wages they earn
while some of the wealthiest americans
avoid paying anything close to that fair
share
my pam revitalizes in the capacity
of the irs to crack down on a number of
studies from
the former secretary of treasury on that
millionaires and billionaires are able
to avoid taxes
and cheat in avoiding those taxes
because we have so few agents
in the irs the consensus is
if you increase the disclosure
requirements
for banks and financial institutions on
accounts of the wealthiest
americans to reduce tax cheating you
will have two steps
two steps would recover 70 billion
dollars per year
that currently goes unreported and
unpaid now that we've been hearing about
this for the last 10 years
instead of cutting the number of ratios
we should be increasing the number of
regions
not hounding anyone just being able to
get access to information
and shut down all the tax havens from
the islands to anyway i won't go into it
i get a little carried away with this
but look and we can take this money
this money and pay for universal pre-k
for every three and four-year-old in
america
so what is better making people just pay
their fair share
paid family need child care costs of
working families
maximum of seven percent of their income
again it's a choice it's more important
to shield millionaires from paying their
fair share or is it more
important that every child gets a real
opportunity to succeed from an early age
and ease the burden on working families
third we have a loophole in our tax
system called stepped-up basis
it's also known as a trust fund loophole
for example
if i had a million dollars in stock that
i bought and it made a million dollars
and i was going to cash it in i'd have
to pay capital gain on that
million dollars but if god forbid in a
way go back to where i was on the way to
where
we're talking about and the way to
cash in my stock i got hit by a car and
got killed
i can leave it to my daughter and she
pays no tax a tax that was owed
two seconds earlier it's not an
inheritance tax the tax was owed to
two seconds earlier but that's what
stepped up basis means it's a person
passes away and leaves the stock in
their
son or daughter son or daughter don't
have to pay anything on
that multi-million dollar gain when they
sell that stock
and that's worth a lot of money look it
may be
decent and honorable people they are but
the last thing
americans with around with the amount of
wealth needs is another tax break
we need to make a choice to eliminate
the loophole
only the gains above for people only the
gains above people making two million
dollars a year
but arson a couple a rate of capital
gains rate for people making more than a
million dollars a year
which by the way would affect three
tenths of one percent of all taxpayers
three tenths of one percent of the top
one percent
and close another loophole like the real
estate investment loophole the wealthy
is simply paying the same rate
on their wages of investment income that
raises 40
billion dollars a year for the next 10
years
the reason i'm bothering to do this is i
keep hearing on the press biden's going
to raise your taxes
anybody making less than 400
000 a year will not pay a single penny
in taxes
and we will not increase the deficit
either unlike the last gigantic tax cut
which increased the deficit by two
trillion dollars
it's about balancing the system and
growing the economy
it means wealthy investors no longer pay
lower marginal tax rates than their
secretary pays
their secretary in their office do you
want to know
what that would do that would take that
money and extend the life-changing
middle-class tax cut
and put it in place for american rescue
plan and expand child care
tax credit to i mentioned earlier that
seventeen hundred dollars in the pockets
of family with two kids
four now through through 2025.
look just closing these loopholes by
taxing investment income at the same
rate
for as wages for the wealthiest
americans would have enough to extend
this again through 2025.
so i ask again is it more important to
keep these tax loopholes for
millionaires they're good people not bad
folks
but or would we rather put 7 200 in the
pockets of working moms and dads
every year if they have two children
folks
trickle-down economies economics has
never worked
for too long we've had an economy that
gives every break in the world to the
folks who need it the least
it's time to grow the economy from the
bottom up in the middle out
we can choose to give hard-working
families a break a tax break in effect
we can choose to invest in our students
we can choose an economy that rewards
work
not just wealth and that chooses the
choice i'm making
and the vast majority of american people
support is let's give people a shot
given even half a chance the american
people have never
ever ever left their country now imagine
if we give them a full chance
imagine what we mean for them and their
families and for our country
we're the united states of america
there's nothing nothing
we've been unable to do when we do it
together
so let's get together let's get this
done
because the truth of the matter is that
we can do this
and grow the economy i won't i'll open
all the other statistics but the plan is
estimated to grow the economy another
trillion dollars this will grow
the economy everybody would better all
so i want to thank you all for doing
your part here
to make sure that not only you're
educating
and giving people a real shot a real
shot
at a real life consistent with their
talents and their capacities
not limited because they don't have the
money and we're going to give it to a
lot more people
i promise you i promise you america will
be much stronger for it
because like i said we're setting out a
universal education it wouldn't just be
12 years anymore
it would be it would be those 14 years
16 years i'm talking about
two to start and two at the other end
and as your state is done under your
governor
and your senator and your congress
persons your state if you've got if you
get four years out of here
two tiers out here it's two years
towards a state university
you cut tuition in half for a four-year
degree as well
so there's an awful lot of possibilities
an awful lot of hope
and the good news is i think there's
overwhelming bipartisan support for this
if you look at the polling data
republican voters overwhelmingly
supported
now i just got to get some of my
republican colleagues to support him
so thank you all god bless you and thank
you for the work you're doing
and may god protect our troops thank you
so much
[Applause]
i think by the end of the summer we'll
be in a very different position than we
are now as you know i've worked very
hard to make sure we have
uh over 600 million doses of vaccine
we're going to continue to make sure
that's available
we're going to increase that number
across the board as well
so we can also be helping other nations
once we take care of all americans
and what's happening now is all the talk
about how
people were not going to get shots they
were not going to be involved
look at what that was we were told that
was most likely to be among
people over 65 years of age but now
people over 65 years of age over 80
percent
have now been vaccinated and
66 percent fully vaccinated
and there's virtually no difference
between
white black hispanic asian-american
and so because what we've done under
some criticism
is we have expanded access
to vaccinations to familiar places forty
thousand drug stores now
also all of the community health centers
that are available all across the nation
mobile units going out and it's getting
better and better and better
and so that's why we're leading the
world when i got elected i said in the
first hundred days
we'd get 100 million people vaccinated i
was wrong we've got 230 million
vaccinations
i think i think you'll see
and there's a debate you know and i'll
end with this there's a debate of what
constitutes hurt immunity
is this 70 of the population is it 68
is it 81 the point is
that by the end of the sump right now
every
single person 16 years or older
doesn't have to wait in line can show up
and get a vaccination
now my plead everyone get
vaccinated now please thank you